[Music]
oof
all right in the but what the bag pics
so thanks for having me yeah thanks for
coming over my house no but thanks for
having me here at the place where we do
this I recently had a cartoon studio put
in my home where we just show little
Theory just show cartoon lie upon lie
this next cartoon I want to show you is
from 1931 okay
it's from fam Biren Studios which which
I know you're a big fan big players it
was actually banned from theaters
because someone okay now right there
because in 1931 for your cartoon to be
banned from theaters there needs to be
some real problems rape didn't matter
racism didn't matter I would argue
encouraged yeah yeah well cuz these the
word damn cuz they used the word damn
that was that was it don't use the word
damn so okay so this is a see this this
is called goofy goat antics goofy goofy
go down oh it's a goofy goat it's a
funny go but no official films no this
is real present yeah call it okay goofy
goat antics she's ready okay this is
just what life was like for goats back
then so that's a goat driving his car
sure it's a bad no he's a real [ __ ]
yeah he's really awful you don't need
that doesn't fit oh he's playing his own
horns yeah what would you do and that's
a cow huh sure the whittling cow like
they do know he's little yellow guy
trying to go I enjoyed it okay this face
I wish I could lick my nostrils oh it
took me a minute to understand what was
happening there big yeah pigs hogging
the road yeah as we go as I go by am i
oh oh he's an aristocrat big oh my god
so fun so okay it's just not careful how
you done
a little confused I'm sorry a lot
confused road hog you got it yeah now I
did got it oh no guard McGruff okay so
should not be happy we're in what's just
upsetting this goat isn't that goofy
everything around him is goofy I mean
also why why is there cops stopping
people here is he stopping people he
just sneezed his body weight off oh well
that is obvious car farts are rude cards
so basically people just wanted to see
anything animated yeah no people answer
oh my god motion I nobody cared about
anything good so the plot of this is I
mean there's no plot to this this is
just an I don't even think he's that
goofy that's what you could do in the
car back then
Oh that'd be convenient it's still find
a way to ticket you in LA though am i
right
uh-oh it's a glee club goofy don't ask
if of them sure this feels like a
dragnet episode all right so now he's
killing it you know when you see what
actually people would do then make the
cartoons make sense yeah well we just go
to a room and have Glee now there's
another act cats
save the acid just kicked in
can see the other paths I love it when I
can see cats underwear I forgot who's
watching what and they're watching the
cat okay right
it took me a minute this is on the stage
play the piano and that's goofy goat
still that's a monkey no that is the
goat no that might be another monkey
that's a goat yeah well first of all
he's in the piano so that's a bad and it
exploded no you did that these two
explode but by the way a great great
attitude by the monkey man yeah yeah it
just keeps going and now he's got a oh
no the Scottish tour guess even in
cartoons they sound terrible yeah yeah
that goats like damn it these Scots well
they're still on the show at this point
we were told we don't be late 15 minutes
boof oh right in the bud what the [ __ ]
bag pigs
yeah bag pigs and they all just turn
into a record okay anyone got a question
for the glee club now he's got an
accordion sure so this is father Dave I
think I speak for everyone when I say I
hope this is longer this is what its
gonna be like when the robots take over
well this band really makes it work and
what now there's a bunch of accordions
because that accordion got pregnant I
think you don't know what's going on
it's the original accordion I could just
split it up into three oh this is good
oh cool so goofy goat can turn his horn
into a flute and then accordion acts
like a Cobra
sure right in the taint just a little
well kill it kill it kill it is he
trying to kill him for him these are the
court it's an accordion
someone from the glee club step in yeah
seriously this is oh no oh no I was
gonna take a much weirder turn oh geez I
thought goofy goat was about to get a
different nickname Oh
[Music]
yeah don't look at me after you say sex
stuff you weirdo
oh there's a bird what hey what's
happening so now the Pelican is like
what accordion yeah this is the only
cartoon I've seen that could end at any
moment and be like oh yeah okey yeah
went out of the went out of the building
hey off to heaven and away they go sure
I've seen that fly through this guy oh
no he dropped the accordion
accordion to you oh wait so hey Pelican
turned into a parachute I'd love to see
the storyboards for this one I don't
think there are any Dave and of course
oh the monkey wasn't go to hell oh
they're gonna [ __ ] okay um Dave you know
I'm not I don't miss the nightmarish
versions of the other ones that we've
seen but what the boat sometimes you
don't need a story sometimes it's cool
they just have a goat running around
doing stuff you imagine in 1931 look man
have you seen goofy cow oh my god I love
him everything happens the ending is so
satisfying
[Music]